hola soy honor de khan academy en este
vídeo veremos cómo seleccionar conceptos
individuales en khan academy y
asignarlos como ejercicios en clase o
tarea en casa una forma de crear
asignaturas es a través de la pestaña
contenido esta contiene todo el alcance
y secuencia de cada uno de los cursos
los maestros pueden entrar a cualquier
unidad o lección y seleccionar uno o
múltiples recursos para asignar por
ejemplo esta unidad empieza con un vídeo
de dos minutos un artículo y luego un
ejercicio de siete problemas al hacer
clic en la liga los maestros pueden
visualizar los recursos y ver el vídeo
leer el artículo o revisar el ejercicio
antes de asignarlo a un alumno otra
forma de crear una tarea es en la
pestaña progreso está te muestra el
nivel de progreso de cada alumno y te
puede ayudar a escoger a los alumnos
beneficiados por un ejercicio extra la
última forma de crear asignaturas es
asignar las desde la barra de
herramientas verás la barra de
herramientas una vez que hagas clic en
un recurso individual como si fueras
alumno puedes usar este método para
asignar recursos de cualquier parte de
nuestro sitio incluyendo actividades
de crecimiento y las lecciones de
animación por computadora de pixar cada
vez que tienes una habilidad individual
seleccionan las clases alumnos y pensá
el límite para tus tareas aunque esto es
para el primer periodo puedes hacer
estas tareas para todas tus clases de
una vez o puedes asignar las a ciertos
alumnos en mi clase luego puedes
enviarles a tus alumnos inmediatamente o
guardarlas para asignarlas después las
tareas guardadas se mostrarán en tareas
haciendo clic en la pestaña guardado
también puedes escoger si quieres que
los alumnos reciban las mismas preguntas
en el mismo orden
o varias preguntas seleccionadas al azar
para los ejercicios guiados la mejor
opción es que los alumnos trabajen con
las mismas preguntas para ejercicios
individuales o tareas los alumnos pueden
trabajar con preguntas diferentes ahora
revisaremos la experiencia de los
alumnos en la página principal en la
pestaña tarea los alumnos pueden ver sus
tareas individuales debajo de las metas
de dominio que estén trabajan las tareas
se ordenan por fecha de entrega mientras
los alumnos completan sus tareas y
trabajan las preguntas recibirán
retroalimentación inmediata sobre su
progreso y tú también recibirás esta
información los alumnos pueden intentar
terminar las tareas varias veces
mientras aprenden de sus errores
si asignas te de diferentes problemas
cada alumno recibirá un grupo de
problemas al azar en cada intento las
tareas también se pueden ver y completar
desde las aplicaciones móviles veamos la
información y los reportes que reciben
los maestros para ver el progreso de los
alumnos haz clic en la clase y ve la
pestaña tarea podrás ver un resumen de
la información con el botón por alumno
verás una tabla con el rendimiento del
alumno en todas las tareas que hayas
creado haz clic en el nombre de cada
alumno para ver más detalles incluyendo
su rendimiento en todas las tareas hasta
el momento para un reporte más detallado
haz clic en el botón por tarea cuando
tus alumnos terminen sus tareas puedes
ver su rendimiento haciendo clic en la
fracción en la columna terminado
para cada uno verás el tiempo que les
tomo terminar el número de intentos y el
mejor desempeño
si quieres repasar un concepto
selecciona a ver reporte en este reporte
verás cuáles fueron los problemas que
más se dificultaron intenta discutir un
problema con tus alumnos pueden discutir
el problema y explorar la razón por la
que varios de ellos se confundieron
luego pídeles que compartan sus
conclusiones con el grupo finalmente
muestra la respuesta y discutan las
respuestas incorrectas este reporte es
en vivo y se actualiza cada 15 segundos
mientras los alumnos trabajan por último
2 consejos para los maestros algunos
conceptos se llevan muy bien con los
maestros y los ejercicios guiados
consideran seleccionar los conceptos que
son más difíciles o que crearán una
buena conversación y debate empieza por
lo básico y asigna pocos conceptos a la
vez esto te ayudará a encontrar una
rutina para usar la información y los
reportes que mejor se adapten a tu salón
de clases para más información visita
khan academy punto o hereje diagonal
visuales